oh if you didn't check out my bio mutant
live stream last month what are you
doing
it was really fun i really enjoyed the
game and i was very honored to be one of
the first to play it
maybe no i wasn't why did i lie about
that
i was the first to play it it i'll
stick with it it's really cool
swedish developers so you know better
link is in the description if you want
to check it out i recommend it
go support videos just that's it on with
video
ken felix you're married man
i'm married i'm married man whoa
but can we spot non-married man
probably i i'd imagine pretty easily
yeah they stick out like a thumb yeah
like just too easy yeah too easy do you
fart in front of each other
do you the real questions
where do you wear the paints or not oh
wait what do you mean where the pants
who oh in the family who wears the pants
in your family
well obviously me oh
because i'm the strongest i'm looking in
the background right now see if marzia
is peeking in
and you're the strongest
you don't have pillow hands you got
masculine
calloused working hands and i wear those
pants so high up my hair don't even see
my face
is that is that a side of like your
power the higher the parents
the pants
all right here we go we brought together
seven married people
i am married i am married
i don't trust the first one but he could
be that oddball in there right he's got
that mustache though his wife told him
to look good so that's why he wears it
and obviously it doesn't so
wives don't like mustache oh that's a
good point
that's a good point actually you're
right mary loves my mustache
i got a mustache right now how dare you
yeah
i had a mustache and said didn't like it
so i shaved it
my pants dropped to the hill oh
i hope they don't have something lame
we're like yeah i was married but i'm a
widow now or something stupid right that
has to be a single loser
yeah yeah is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
oh i thought there would be couples for
some reason but yeah this makes sense
okay entire prize okay how about this
we pick uh who we think it is from the
first round and whoever gets it is
has the best plans whoever gets has the
best pants
yeah that's the most worthy i can think
of
best mustache best mustache okay
i think you might be single well i've
been married for three years
she targeted me right away she said you
are not married i was like
what a question is how long have you
guys been married quick everybody
oh i saw him only because he diverted
the question right away
that's what i do in amogas do you see
the guy rick that has like the hat on
and the earring
i don't know if he's married or not but
he looks like he would just be the worst
person in the world to talk to
i'm just i'm just judging straight off
the bat
everyone watching this with their hat
and earring is just like bruh
i mean you're right no no normal person
is gonna look like rick come on where's
he at where is he at look at that look
at that did you see him
who is this what is this freaking kid
rock get out of here
no one's just gonna love that he's like
50 years old this guy's long hair he's
probably bald on top he's got his hat
come on rick take care of yourself bro
you gotta
get his bracelet on because he went to
like a couple minutes firing left and
right today okay well we did record a
video and it made me mad so no
no just going after everybody rick don't
take it personal ken is just having a
day okay
i like your hat a lot oh my god i've
been married what 50 years
just two years like last week two months
it feels like 15 19 years ago i'm so
sorry i lied
oh it's her
it'd be weird to lie like that though i
don't think it's her
she forgot she got her anniversaries
it's right here it's raised married
this past may so like four months come
on all these newly married
that that is not even mary you're not
even married i just got married for this
video
i don't know did this dude actually get
married anthony over here uh he's making
me
he's making me feel ways bad ways what
kind of ways are you feeling
he's got shorts i appreciate that he's
got like he's got his cool shoes on he
got his hot socks
got his look at these shorts and his
black t-shirt and his mustache and
i don't know he's he's giving me
whiplash of like a 40 year old dude in
like a
trunk he's either 20 or 40. i can't
figure out which
he dresses like he's 20. i'll give him
that but he does look
too old for that look i don't know man
yeah that's how kids dress ken
you don't know this high socks funky
shoes oh god it's me
i got black shirt too
oh man we got to wear black shirts you
know because when you record you start
sweating you don't want to like you know
you know show off all this no no no
don't say that don't don't expose me
like that no i wear black shirts because
it's
i say 50 but actually it feels like 50.
does everyone believe
does everyone believe in traditional
marriage if you're married then yeah you
do
right what i don't know what do you mean
what does that mean
who do we think what is the question who
do we think that's not married here who
do we pick
we're not done with round yet okay okay
first round right yeah
wedding rings all that stuff yes yeah
yes okay everybody yes or no yeah young
others i mean okay
the first thing you have to do is detail
put your hands out let's see your
just see your bands what the is he
on about
is he magician what is he gonna do he's
like oh you got you got you
i don't have a ring on right now i'm
sorry mary but so you got you got like
marks on your ring finger yeah yeah yeah
because you've been wearing your
wrinkles you're done take the ring off
ken how could you
well my fingers started getting like dry
and flaky underneath it so i
got i don't know if you can see on the
camera i got like a red mark like
here oh you have little sensitive hands
can i understand
how dare you make fun of my
does anyone does everyone have their
chance because if you're married you've
got you've got a tan line
i have a crazy tan line that's a good
point i don't have a tan line because i
live in uk
yeah i have a white
band around my ring finger how about
insanity you tell me the day you go
so she has all right yeah i guess it
wears down the skin a bit
she gave us like the the flipping the
bird when you're like you know it looked
like she
it was a little aggressive candy
this guy over here oh my god you guys
are like doing finger stuff
no one look at my hand please nope
hold on hold on look at it hold it don't
you just hug me your hand
he asked you questions he was pointing
putting people on blast
or not that's no we never have that you
have it you have that
right you have just haven't you hit
yours
okay anthony's kind of sucks for not
engaging in that
am i right you don't think anything
looks suspicious because anthony it's
just
he is just us like his whole everything
is suss about anything look at him
he is definitely the one that stands out
the most as well and he's acting the
most suspicious but there's always that
wild card in there so i'm not convinced
yet
okay okay it was a good round to observe
the others
he's fiddling with his ring a lot do you
do that uh
yeah i kind of do it on like my hand i
got like a fiddle thing where i like
roll it around okay
like this oh that's something that you
do when it's new and you're like oh
what's this on my finger
i guess people still do it then okay he
gets the pass
oh i think anthony's out yeah boy
and then there is 15 seconds left i
personally pounce on it because i was
grateful that it wasn't me
oh bye bye anthony
okay we had the first round who do you
think it is i would guess
i'm guessing the old dude i'm guessing
the old dude i think they put him in
here because they'd be like oh this
sweet old man is definitely married
or i would say he's never been married
ever like look at him
i would guess one of these two on the
left oh yeah
not really yeah one of those well he's
got his flip-flops
i'm just going with the old man because
i feel like i don't i feel like that's
could try the wild card i don't know
maybe yeah but that's a good point
well i i picked two so maybe you should
pick two too then okay uh i picked yeah
i picked the older guy and rick
because rick is okay probably definitely
divorced
luck because i'm very very married
what day was you married because i got
married october 11th which is my
birthday
oh really that's my husband's birthday
august 17th is actually
three on our three-year anniversary oh
wonderful
and you i got one question for you and
i'll stop
no i'm asking you rick wants to like put
people on the spot i look forward
to this yeah what's the date rick what
day you get married rick come on yeah
was that spring wedding you said
mm-hmm mm-hmm okay what day whatever
2003 yeah okay you november 7
2000 okay january 28 2017.
okay good night eighteen right not that
anyone asked
yeah everybody can just make up a date
here who cares if people ask me about
today i'll be like
uh okay let's see here two thousand and
uh
i wouldn't know right away is that weird
i mean
is that like the the married um joke
that like
oh i forgot our anniversary you know
i would never never ever
you know the weird thing about this like
the old guy again
i'm focusing on the old guy he got
married in 2000 right how old was he in
like still 16 years ago
yeah that's a bit sus good point it was
pretty late
that is very late that is sus is hell
hmm maybe you're right about him don't
mind
how long were you married uh let me see
um it'll be 30 years 30 years what did
you say before that i'm the first yes
exactly yeah well i was joking with you
it feels exactly what i caught too
what was something that went wrong in
your guys's wedding we had an all-white
wedding everybody were all white
and one lady came in purple and that
would piss me off i believe that
that's a good story how dare purple
what went wrong on our wedding because
one thing went wrong
oh yeah the dj played his own
songs first
we have to tell him we gave you a
playlist just play the playlist
all you need to do is to press play
okay you're not you're nothing
like why did you fire me this is not
because literally the venue only let you
choose a couple of djs and we had no
options
okay
there was only an approved list of
vendors so you could search up the
prices and get reference across the
boys yeah it was a nice wedding i
enjoyed it
yeah yeah everybody everybody's like
yeah
ken you said you're at the wedding but
we don't see you in either pictures they
always put me in the front
when you guys first walked out and then
they take pictures of the end so i was
always like way in the background
okay look my ear is like in the main
picture that they always show of his
wedding okay my ear
right you were definitely there well i
know what one thing you would say was
wrong about the wedding
what the portion sizes oh my god dude
they're like come out would you like a
snack and i'm like
bruh felix where's your food at dude
and you're like i know what the heck
they need to bring it out
it was very mild portion i'll give you
that i mean god damn it
and i thought for sure we had these
little pizzas things as a hors d'oeuvres
and i kept asking for them and then
apparently we never chose them
yeah i remember like we was at the hotel
or whatever mary's like so we get
something to eat before we go i'm like
no no i have food there it's fun this
would be great
and i got there and i was like ravenous
i'm like there were
there were modest portions i'll oh i'll
say that but i am
it was pretty nice i had like the guys
playing the music over there
yeah it was a nice wedding playing the
wrong music kane what the the guys
playing the violins
oh that was nice they were great yeah
they were awesome yeah
i don't even know she was not invited my
best friend was late to my wedding and
that kind of pissed me off because i
noticed when he was totally
well i have to say there nothing went
wrong uh
which is something we're married three
times yeah
that's us he's some more such obsessed
you're out
you're out he's perfect he has a
mustache and the other social person has
more sex
mustache plus marriage it doesn't work
everyone knows things
excuse me i've already told you i have a
mustache right now how why are you
are you tara's weird
i guess i mean if i had to lie about
being married i wouldn't lie about being
married three times
right that would be too elaborate to
come up with three different dates and
three different
stories and right right so maybe that
makes him clear
maybe i don't know let's go oh maybe
maybe maybe he's maybe he's okay maybe
he's so great
maybe he's too harsh you're not too
harsh he's not okay
look at him he's looking like he's he's
part of a laundry commercial i mean come
on
he's gonna tell us about his diabetes in
a minute
diabetes it went so smoothly it had me i
was actually crying
let's let's look at detail here pay
attention to detail not just the
questions
look at detail reactions look what's up
i'm here to win
so i want to make sure everyone sounds
like something a lyre would say
someone who's talking the truth you're
the lord no no he's that it is
definitely not
rick oh boy definitely not he's man he's
trying
yeah it's very annoying he's looking but
he's definitely not it
like what what is that that whole street
what's that even do like what
did he did he just loot something out
you know what i like to do guys
i like to find details okay i'm the man
yeah let's put his little finger at like
look at my hands okay guys what i like
to do check this out
check this out check his fingers check
this out can you bring it over here
i'm looking for details he's like i'm
really low on cash right now i didn't
need this for me i need to win
yeah take it back i think he's never
married yeah
sure man's playing too much
he's been accustomed to it for way too
long class actions
plaintiff's side yeah they make a lot of
money right if lawyers want to get
married make a lot of wonders
but it's very dangerous guys we can't
focus on her job now
who do you think they're voting out now
i don't know
maybe the guy with the fanny pack and
all these props rick is going out
whoa what got it
he's got a family bag he's got a face
what the is that
all right rick i see you rick going out
there with your fanny pack
and your kid rock look what is he gonna
what is he gonna pull out of his fanny
pack
oh my god probably candy thank you very
much
always remember the obvious is always
your worst enemy if you don't pay
attention oh my god
what the was that so he took out
his wedding ring
so that if he goes out he'll be like
guys
remember it's freaking annoying things
are not always
as they seem surprised i have a wedding
congratulations i guess yeah i guess you
went out and lost
because you're idiot okay great
thanks right it's about elimination
at the right time and it it just it ran
out for me
he's angry you got eliminated at the
wrong time what are you on about mate
buddy stupid in a ring
i feel like we got the wrong guy out i
was like we still have candice in here
there's something about candice there's
something about canvas
it feels like i come from that
institution so
we don't believe in divorce you know we
don't divorce our husbands we bury them
candice what the damn hate to be
married all right geez yeah she's
definitely married all right
joke about that 100
all right i don't believe her now she's
over explaining it she's killed a couple
husbands
that is not something you shake so
casually
i mean if you're married maybe as long
as she's been married
you know
i'm scared
you know she was out there how old is
your significant other
my husband is 35. and you are
i'm 55.
dang are you sure she didn't kill one
and down you know upgrade a little bit
and get a younger younger model oh my
goodness
she's 20 years older than him goddamn
but she said she was going to bury him
we putting together here her husband
is 35 but she's saying i'm gonna bury
him she's ready to die pack it up in 10
years this guy will be 45
it's candace it's candice it's candice
okay we got it we got her all right all
right
what are you going to get it well i mean
i hear what you're saying but leave me
berry
she's going to live a whole lifetime
while she's gone i don't know i feel
like you lost the joke there she just
said like
they don't believe in divorce like the
only way that she's going to not be
married is by
killing her i get it but that implies
that usually the man dies first because
you're the same age and guys don't live
as long as women
but clearly that's not the case in this
ending because it's an area
so you don't get it what do you mean i
don't get it i
get it you don't get it okay
i still think it's the old dude what i'm
i'm playing this video
what screw you and you're flipping
mustache all right you're lucky you're
married
at all oh my god yeah i bet you don't
even have pants in your sh
relationship i got short zone right now
i bet your kids are
just i don't want to bring your kids in
this i'm not
first thing that i saw were her legs
even it might advance me
and i find man eh all right
if it ain't if he ain't the mole i
respect them immensely
gonna eye for legs so you
yeah and and she was no youngster let me
tell you and
that's what surprised that's amazing and
everything else
worked out fine oh yeah you start with
the legs
you can't go wrong apparently oh
yeah yeah right dude i gotta ask why
does everyone get married so young in
america
divorce rate is 50 yeah yeah
and i always feel like it's cause people
get married so young
right well there's a lot of different
reasons right there's like the kind of
in america there's the whole like high
school sweetheart kind of thing
oh right like all the girl you're dating
in high school like oh you you
want to marry her kind of thing and then
that that's great i don't doubt that
you're in love but
you changed as people yeah vastly from
when you're 18 to your
your 30s or late 20s at least i've never
understood it either i've always
questioned that like why
why why get married you're like 18 years
old what
how about don't you know if your
relationship hinges on whether or not
you're getting married or not then it's
kind of a flimsy relationship to begin
with
it also seems like people get married as
a last resort like oh our relationship
is a bit rocky i better propose well
that's what
yeah i'll put them on blast that's
that's what dumb people do
yeah but that seems to be very common
i need to save this relationship uh a
big commitment here
well we'll save this get married that'll
change everything not not working on our
issues we'll just get married
right yeah honestly it annoys me a
little bit because like marriage
the divorce rate okay sure divorce
happened there's nothing
inherently wrong about it but i feel
like the reason it's so high
is because people jump on this like a
romantic dream that is often
in movies where you fall in love really
quickly but you need to also be able to
live together
function together deal with your own
issues at least if the other person
can't help you with them
yeah but people just get married and it
blows my mind i'm like
what and it's seen as a nice thing i've
seen so many couples on youtube
like come and go come and go we got
married and i feel like that's another
part of it where like you're
incentivized to get married because
yeah well that's what people want people
that did it on youtube
i mean like vlog families i'm just gonna
you know throw the vlog families out
there they literally have kids just
because it brings more views
so it's like right exactly and it's so
weird and gross and they do it with
everything and
i hate it because it's so it's that the
world
where it's soils yeah beauty
you're ruining it you're spitting on
this sacrimonious
faction you've been pulling the big word
during a sacrimonious
i don't even know what that means okay
i don't know i don't mean i don't want
to judge people that going through
everywhere but it just seems like
can you just wait like another two years
yeah well
there's a lot of a lot of that people
get married for certain reasons right
bam don't get married boom don't propose
i'm like just get married just get
married
for the right reasons don't get married
because you have a kid don't get married
because the last thing for your
relationship get married because
you want to don't have kids either stop
having kids
what we got we can just have kids that's
another person
you can't just sell another person out
of nowhere people do it all the time
it's easy yeah but they should stop it's
very annoying
i got more you want more i mean i'm
gonna have more kids
you know i got my third kid on the way
yeah but you're married and it's great
it's beautiful
okay i thought it's like it's like don't
get married don't have kids i'm like
what are we gonna do felix
we should all die okay rhinos are
extinct now and we did this
she said that her husband was 35 but
they've been married for 30 years and so
i was like
so your husband was did she say that oh
that's what they picked up on
really well i mean
oh god maybe the cops will come in at
the end of the episode
we'll take her away chris hansen's about
to walk in jesus
i told you bro i told you i told you
i say this okay you're wrong all right
you're wrong that's definitely a glaring
hole in the story right there wow
sorry bye bye
can we ask them like she's just like
what excuse me
is my reaction so that's the best
footage
they set up this shot and be like all
right so you just got eliminated
what just happened what do you see your
thoughts right
i feel like she said a lot and then they
just cut it to the she like yeah
so like italy was like they did she
didn't really say anything
did she all right she had a lot of
choice words they couldn't chew
she just went on a big range so these
how dare they can we shoot their hands
again yes yo
mine's like oh yeah you're the only one
that doesn't really have a thing
no i i i don't wear a ring why don't you
wear a ring
i never have i don't wear a ring so
i figured the best thing to do is of
course
i believe that maybe that's yeah again
some people don't wear the ring
i mean i got mine on right now but i
mean if i leave the house without the
ring on you know i'm getting some looks
to leave the door you know i mean
so yeah mary with the binoculars
and the sniper rifle she's like you're
not proud of me what are you doing you
know we're in your ring you're married
to me what are you doing out there where
are you going
you you look out to the car open the
door you see a lightsaber pointing at
your chest
where you think you're going with that
ring on right now
it hasn't worked out too well for me in
the past
no no i'm a great that's a good recovery
though it's gonna come
i have always loved me if he if it's not
him he's a good liar
because he's such i'll give him that i
don't know i feel like he's over
explaining everything he's he's got like
the most story of anybody so far
he's told the most is this a rule when
people over explain that it's a lie
yeah i think so like when people like
okay too many details
yeah uh but maybe not i don't know maybe
he's just talking
he don't wear a ring though even though
he's got a ring on his pinky finger
right there
yeah that is very sus too i would vote
him out next
just for safety believe in the
institution strongly
it would be unfair to base the decision
solely on
oh you don't have a tan line there's a
lot of reasons why someone might not
wear a ring
okay i'm not going to lie i'm so
suspicious of everyone on
that yeah she hasn't really said
anything at all dude yes that's the
safest way just be
silent yeah i just i was like who the
are you i don't even know your name
where'd you come from what the
she's doing the moga strat i'm not
speaking mm-hmm
okay you know what's going on if we're
gonna talk about who we're supposed to
be i think you two are suspicious
because you're asking all the questions
and asking
i'm an attorney like what i'm trying to
ask questions
you're asking me all this question in
him but you're not asking her any
questions
yeah i don't know i feel like really
confident
she's got them all wrapped around her
finger she's the master oh my god
she's like oh but like we trust each
other
she's manipulating women look at me now
i think you might be suspicious right
now ask me like any question you want in
the next 47 seconds
one year september look she dodged it it
went to her but they were suspicious of
her
yeah you know she's just sitting there
watching you know she's not saying
it's hard my husband's 27 he's turning
28 on october 11.
another cougar huh look at him
saying anything off right there say
something
he called her a cougar
she called her a cougar i missed that
what did she say he called her a cougar
he's like you know your old lady getting
those young men
how old is she i don't know i don't know
so story then i add up he believed in
traditional marriage he believed
everything about marriage
but he never thought about wearing a
ring i'm like that makes no sense to me
saul's gone oh my god saul's gone
good luck i don't think it's all getting
so happy up there
because i'm like i think i'm confident
in us three and we're going to split the
money
no it's her she's the devil demon
look at her smile there it's her she
went right under our radar ken but she
was
right in plain sight
oh my god she wanted to stop there you
know
yeah yeah yeah you think they're going
to vote out the the one guy remaining
like the yeah the ladies they band
together yeah
it becomes a bonding thing and they're
like yeah
we're going and then oh it was you
you're going to put your hand up i
didn't feel that i felt that
she felt that way and i'm not gonna lie
i feel like when i started asking you
questions
you got really defensive and tried to
push back i just figured that
i do oh now how do you describe this
i just made this up thank you
but that's why i didn't put my head up
because i believed in you guys and now
you guys are really changed my mind oh
my god
i don't know i'm sorry i don't know i i
don't know what to trust
i have much regret about having
initiated the vote
sorry oh my god the pressure got to me i
hate to vote now
it's okay i'm a dude
you cannot throw your vote okay better
stay
okay you can't do that
oh she went remote damn
shady this is getting spicy usually
there's not this few people
yeah usually they stop at like four or
three
all right it's not good oh my god if you
could trade me i'll never
trust another woman again
oh no oh whoa please
please red please god i beg
i beg i just want red
i knew it i knew it damn it i wanted i
wanted the betrayal yeah i wanted
betrayal
she would have looked so evil it would
have been so beautiful
wait so who is it then damn okay
well i know we guessed at the beginning
yeah i still i i guess the old man
that's still i still think that i do i'm
going with kane this
i was still just relieved that ali
didn't like jump up and be like just
kidding it's me
thank god i know i got towards the end i
was like in the mall please step forward
and reveal himself can this
you better step oh okay okay
rick
holy well you can't take a book by
it's called
but you're married to your five-year-old
according to your story
i've been married three times it just
didn't quite work out for me oh he's
okay it's the divorce story oh my god
stop it you believe in the tricksters
damn it he's been married dang it saul
well you got it right ken i just picked
him because he i thought they were
trying to bamboozle with like ah here's
an old guy they'll never guess him right
and yeah yeah reverse yeah big
brain you have the better mustache i
hate to say it man
thank you thank you yes my wife does it
it's a great looking mustang
thank you it looks yeah i guess it works
i guess i was wrong think stink
i love that part it's so good that's
going to be you
to your kids oh man i hope i can get
that swole you treat mary as your pant
pain
she's like a pet to me but i can live
for a couple of thousand years that'd be
great
the three strike rule no more marriages
okay fair enough hey
they really just voted out uh what was
his name is crazy it's
like mark or something oh yeah yeah yeah
they just voted them out
they just like you can't have any money
they knew that yeah he's just sitting
over there right now
like what i felt some regret for all of
the other people who had been voted out
but i also felt pretty good about
winning
wow wow really rubbing in the money
he's just sitting over there being salty
right now like they're over there
that was more crap rick is the only one
that's satisfied because he got to pull
out his little ring straight oh my god
things are never why won't they appear
i'm rick street magic
street magician here's my card rick the
kind of dude that
that asks for people to sub in the
comments i don't think candace
understands that she messed up in her
story she's over here like i should have
lied a little bit
say you're married for 30 years he's 35
years old i mean i don't know
yeah i don't wonder you got voted out
get out of here candace is literally me
if i was part of this competition i'm
being like well i guess like what
what did you do did you lie your face
off what happened i didn't
you didn't watch the most epic reveal of
all time
no i they just thought my avatar was
cringe so they're like oh that's dumb
blow them out
first round let's go got him
well good episode good jubilee
subscribe to ken because ken has the
better mustache congratulations you can
thank you finally subscribe recognize
did you say yeah
all right that's the end of the video
thank you for watching
and see you next time
yeah it's you billy it's not jubilee
it's jubilee
it's jacket it's jeans
okay ken do you say yeah or do you say
yeah it's 11.
there's no it's literally the same thing
it's a yay
yeah same sound yeah and you don't go j
the difference
yeah how do you spell yeah it doesn't
matter because it said the same thing
and it's the way it says that makes a
difference
no there's no difference oh my god
yeah no yeah oh i would like to go and
get some
all right oh jiha
what are you talking about uh oh i like
to judo
you jude lay oh my god you're saying all
these words
nice to meet you ken that's been great
thank you
do you yump what do you mean jump let me
go
you jump
listen i've said this before the
language is a changing thing
okay fluid it's like a flow fluid river
that goes swoosh
and it's changed by influential people i
am influential people
and i can change what i don't like okay
okay yes
i am that arrogant on my authority
so i will make it a thing and i hope
anyone listening
will agree with my logic and it will
change it so that i'm right
thank you that's in the video